today on the matt walsh show senator
josh hawley provokes mockery and cheers
from the media for suggesting that
there's an attack on masculinity in our
culture but he's completely correct of
course in fact the situation is even
worse than he describes masculinity is
in its death throws in the west and if
masculinity dies the west will go down
with it we'll talk about why also
another day another prosecution witness
in the kyle rittenhouse case
accidentally destroys the prosecution's
case and a new poll says that 70 of
americans are experiencing anxiety and
depression because of climate change can
that possibly be true plus snopes does a
fact check on the claim that joe biden
let one rip in front of a member of the
royal family enter a daily cancellation
we'll discuss the republican party's
embrace of sexual identity politics with
the newly christened rnc pride coalition
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
well as we engage in this ongoing
culture war you know one of the best
things you can do one of the most
effective things you can do uh for the
culture but also as it happens you know
just to make your life a lot easier is
become a customer of charity mobile
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice with five
percent of your monthly plan price and
they've sent millions of dollars to
charities so far
um that's the charity part of it but
it's also just a great service as i've
discovered i've been a customer of
charity mobile for i don't know two
years now new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping when you
mention offer code walsh plus you get a
free christmas gift with every phone
from charity mobile while supplies last
that's another thing that you're not
going to find from the other
mobile phone carriers i can tell you
that charity mobile makes it easy to
switch you can keep your existing phone
number you may even be able to keep your
existing phone as well but if you need a
new phone no problem charity mobile has
a variety of options from basic flip
phones and low cost smartphones to the
latest 5g phones ask about their new
flip phone with parental controls that
allow you to disable mobile data usage
text and picture messaging and much more
which which is great because if your kid
is going to have a phone there's no
reason for them to have a smartphone
with the internet on it so i love that
charity mobile is doing that switch to
charity mobile and support the causes
you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662
and mention offer code walsh so as a
general rule if you say something and
the media catches wind of it and reacts
as though it's the dumbest craziest most
asinine thing anyone has ever said in
the whole history of the human race then
you can be pretty confident that you
were right not only not only right but
right in a very important way about a
crucial topic that they are terrified to
even acknowledge or talk about
republican senator josh hawley of
missouri has provoked this kind of
over-the-top overcompensating reaction
after delivering a speech at the
national conservative conference a few
days ago about the attack on manhood
and masculinity in our culture then he
discussed the same subject in an axios
interview yesterday which we'll play in
a minute and between the speech and the
interview he has been widely mocked and
derided by the left and the media
attack on masculinity what attack on
masculinity that's absurd they declare
in an article on cnn.com gloria borger
called holly's claim conspiratorial it's
a conspiracy theory rolling stone called
it bizarre msnbc said the whole idea of
an attack on masculinity is hilarious
and empty
kevin mcdermott in st louis today
accused holly of mansplaining
and yet the fact that a man would use
the term mansplaining only proves the
point that masculinity is in deep
decline
at least when it comes to that
particular guy but i think it's it's
even the problem is more widespread than
that even the guy interviewing holly for
axios seems kind of flummoxed by the
notion that the people who use phrases
like toxic masculinity may also be
waging an assault on masculinity a thing
which they think is toxic
let's listen to some of that exchange
what's a man to you paint a picture
what's a man well a man is a father a
man is a husband a man of somebody who
takes responsibility as conservatives
we've got to call men back to
responsibility we've got to say that
spending your time not working and we
have more and more men who are not
working spending your time on video
games spending your time watching porn
online while doing nothing is not good
for you your family or this country so
viewers watching in this and they're
thinking really what the liberals are
doing are going to push me to watch
pornhub more or play donkey kong more do
you mean that little
well what i mean literally is that i
think the liberal attack the left-wing
attack on manhood says to men you're
part of the problem it says that your
your masculinity is inherently
problematic it's inherently oppressive
what's your basis for linking that to
what liberals or the left as you would
say do is that based on data or based on
a hunch
well it's policy over many years i mean
if you look at the policy of
deindustrialization those are policy
choices mike pursued over many years
i've looked wait how does that connect
to porn
oh well if you've got you've got men 16
million men mike who are idle who don't
have anything to do now partly that's
their own responsibility but also partly
because jobs have dried up in many
cities across america and rural areas
too i think you put together lack of
jobs you put together fatherlessness you
put together the social messages that we
teach our kids in school i think we've
got to confront that and its effects
what's a man well he's not someone who
wears those kinds of socks that that
guy's wearing um holly is of course
right about
everything he said and he could go he
could have gone much further if the
other guy didn't cut him off every four
seconds there is indeed much more to be
said and i think we could break this
subject down into three parts three
questions
how do we know that masculinity is
declining
why is it declining
and why is it a problem that it's
declining so i'm going to try to answer
answer all three in just a few minutes
though this will be far from a
comprehensive treatment but we'll go
through this first how do we know that
masculinity is declining well simply
because every single relevant societal
marker is pointing in that direction i
mean every single one
record numbers of men are not working as
holly
alludes to
not fulfilling the masculine role of
provider even if they just be providing
for themselves
and a great many of them would be
providing only for themselves if they
provided at all because record numbers
of men have never married millions more
were married but no longer are or else
they had just they you know they had
kids but never got married leading to a
growing crisis of fatherless homes
in the education system
boys are falling behind girls get better
grades more girls end up going to
college now that going to college is
actually a good idea in most cases but
that's the way it leads boys are far
more likely to drop out to be expelled
to be suspended they're also far more
likely to be judged so incorrigible and
uncontrollable that they have to be put
on psychotropic psychotropic drugs
out in the world away from the confines
of the education system men are
experiencing epidemics of drug abuse and
homelessness
violent crime is surging and men are
most likely to be both the perpetrator
and the victim when it comes to violent
crime
as holly indicates men are increasingly
retreating into cyberspace
replacing physical reality with a
virtual reality
americans spend collectively billions of
hours billions watching porn and men
account for most of that but certainly
not all
the average gamer spends a little over
eight hours a week playing video games
which may not sound like much meaning
it's an hour a day or so
but that's an entire extra work day
spent playing with a toy and that's the
average okay which means that a large
portion are playing much more than that
two times three times four times that
amount in a recent survey a third of
respondents said that they skip
showering they skip socializing they
skip eating so they so that they can
play more video games
many gamers you know complain that video
games are unfairly maligned in these
kinds of conversations and they're
probably right that an hour a day spent
playing video games is not much
different from an hour spent you know
watching tv or scrolling social media
the fact is that most of us are spending
way too much time on all of that
and it's not like gamers are only
playing video games and not using the
internet or watching tv they've just
added an additional chunk of screen time
still as a pound for pound comparison an
hour spent staring at netflix is no
better or more worthwhile than an hour
on games that's that's true i would
agree with that
the difference though
is that games are more immersive
they're able to take the place of
physical reality in a much more
convincing and seemingly complete way
which means that they have a greater
tendency to dominate your life
not every gamer is dominated by games
but many are they eat sleep and breathe
games
they've all but dropped out of society
in favor of games that's where it
becomes dangerous
games are not the only culprit though in
general modern western men are obsessed
with toys of various kinds
and recreation
we are much much less likely than our
grandfathers to develop actual useful
physical skills
or even hobbies that involve doing
physical things out in the physical
universe
someone said to me yesterday they said
well what's the difference between
playing video games all day or going
fishing well i don't think you should be
playing video games or fishing all day
you should be doing you should be
working and providing for your family
but can you really not see a difference
in one case you're out in nature you're
you're exp you're breathing fresh air
you're outside you're
you're you know
you're developing a survival skill
um you're doing something that people
have been doing a skill that people have
been utilizing since ancient times i
mean there's clearly a difference
between those two things
whether it's video games or tv or
watching sports or obsessing over
children's comic books and cartoons men
have become softer more frivolous more
useless
women have their own corresponding
problems that are often just as severe
yet not exactly the same that's a
different subject though as women are
different from men
right now
what we're establishing what we need to
establish
is that men are in fact in crisis
and if men are in crisis
then masculinity is in crisis because
masculinity by definition relates to the
qualities and attributes that are
characteristic of men
now why is this happening
another complex question that requires a
longer answer than i can provide but in
brief we know for one thing
that there's been a dramatic decline in
testosterone levels among men over the
last several decades this is a
documented fact
and the decline is incredibly extreme i
mean something like one percent
reduction per year on average in
testosterone so if you look around today
and you see a striking number of soft
feminine
girly sorts of men that's not your
imagination that's a very real
biological phenomenon
which is uh which is which is you know
that's driving this the drop in
testosterone probably has something to
do with environment probably has
something to do with diets
it's also a self-perpetuating thing
men with less testosterone are less
inclined to go out and exercise and
compete you know do competitive sorts of
games
but a lack of exercise is one of the
things that can cause lower testosterone
obesity is associated with testosterone
deficiency as well
but it's not all biological boys from a
young age enter into a society
where masculinity and masculine impulses
are actively discouraged and punished
most boys will be in the government
school system starting from the age of
four or younger
i mean joe biden wants kids there
starting when they're like two
and that is a system
the government education system is a
system run by women
and designed for girls
there is no time or space or patience
for boys with aggression and energy in
other words boys who act like boys are
not welcome in the system
those traits are not just discouraged
but they're treated as diseased
as symptoms of mental illness
girls are a lot better at sitting still
memorizing things being calm you know
you can sit them down at a desk and give
them an activity and they can sit and do
that for hours potentially
boys are much less likely to have that
ability
naturally which is why the school system
will look at a boy that you know
struggles to sit there and sit still and
do boring things and say he's diseased
but
stuff some drugs in his mouth
boys who will not be broken will
eventually be drugged their boyhood is
literally medicated out of existence
sometimes this can take on a very direct
and extreme form as our culture the
school system and many families
encourage boys to dress as girls and
quite literally become girls or try to
become girls anyway
this is a process helped along or really
driven in the home many boys not only go
to schools run by women and designed for
girls but they live in homes
run by women and designed for girls
either they have no father in the home
or the father father has a physical
presence yet an empty shell
a cuckolded eunuch who allows his wife
to lead the family while he goes off to
watch porn and play with his toys
this is the environment many boys find
themselves in and there will be no
relief as they grow older and enter into
an adult world that is just as hostile
if not more
to masculinity than the school system
and his homework
so all of this
or rather you add all of this to the
overarching societal pressure both men
and women constantly feel to experience
life as passive consumers and viewers
and we begin to see quite clearly how we
end up with a society overrun by passive
weak emasculated
effeminate men
but is this a problem
i mean do we actually need manly men
yeah we do
no society in history has ever thrived
absent of masculinity
none
now granted none were ever crazy enough
to try we are in many ways attempting to
blaze a new trail here but it will not
lead to anywhere or anything but ruin
what what role has masculinity
traditionally played in society
well men have been the fighters they've
been the hunters the builders the
protectors the providers
men have also traditionally led in
fields like science and math the great
majority of technological advancements
and discoveries have been made by men
that's a fact
and it's not a coincidence nor is it the
result of women being excluded and
anything the thing about a
about a pioneer a genius you know
someone who discovers things
and changes the course of civilization
you can't exclude them
they are going to have their influence
on the world so the fact that
when it comes to math and science it's
mostly been men
that's because men are more inclined in
that direction
men have been the pioneers in multiple
senses of the word men
are especially suited for these various
roles because they're typically stronger
they're typically more competitive and
they're more analytical
which is where the math and science
comes in
men are also bigger risk takers
see women are more emotionally
intelligent they have much greater
empathy while men tend to think more
systematically they tend to care less
about how people feel i'm not just
making this up by the way
i mean this is the experience of every
single human on earth we all know this
inherently because we live in human
society but they've also done studies on
this subject
and these are always the results
in fact i was just reading an article in
the telegraph about the largest study
ever conducted on this subject
about the differences in the way men and
women think
it was a university of cambridge study
of well over half a million people which
is an enormous sample size and it found
exactly this
should be no surprise
in the study women are empathetic
women are more empathetic men are more
logical doesn't mean that men have no
empathy hopefully they're not
psychopaths
and it doesn't mean that women have no
logic they're not insane
but women tend more towards empathy men
tend more towards being logical
now other scientists condemned that
study
when it came out
even though it was again the the biggest
study of its kind very thorough
but other scientists condemned and they
said it's neurosexism
but that only proves the point i'm
making here it is a womanly feminine
approach to get upset about the results
of a study because it might hurt
people's feelings
now we certainly need people in society
who care about feelings but we also need
the manly input which says well to the
to hell with how they feel this is the
truth
this is what we lose
when we lose masculinity
we largely lose not only the benefits of
physical strength
but also the voice of a more detached
somewhat cold logic and reason
a healthy society values both the
feminine and the masculine and it finds
a place for both
yes a role for both
a a gender role if you like
an unhealthy society like ours
thinks that it can shove one half of
that equation out the door
and lock the deadbolt
and leave masculinity out in the cult
but it can't work
society needs masculinity it needs men
they won't function without it
certainly won't thrive without it
and that's a lesson that i think we're
going to learn the hard way
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now thank god i have another chance to
talk about uh what you know is my
favorite subject and that is uh home
financing you know look the home you're
living in right now can cost you less
it's true you can lower your payment and
save thousands long term you just have
to refinance to one of these incredibly
low mortgage rates and do it now before
they're gone i mean if they're expected
to rise in the new year you can't afford
to miss out it takes just a ten minute
call to american financing america's
home for home loans you'll work with a
salary based mortgage consultant
somebody who'll guide you through custom
loan options that can save you up to a
thousand dollars a month uh that's right
a thousand dollars a month is what you
could save and you don't have to reset
your loan to get these kinds of savings
either you can choose any term
10 years and over because you shouldn't
pay interest for years when you don't
need it you can pre-qualify for free at
866-569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 one more time 866 569-4711
or you can visit americanfinancing.net
and you want to make sure you go there
right now take advantage of these deals
because they're going to run out again
visit americanfinancing.net
all right um
i'm
uh trying to forge through here i know
it's it's trite and boring to complain
about daylight savings time
but i can't help it because it causes
very real suffering in my life
as soon as that clock moves back an hour
and everybody's bragging about how oh we
get an extra hour of sleep
all that means for us is that our kids
are up at 5am announced at 6am
so this morning i heard the boys at 5 30
in the morning
wrestling
at 5 30 in the morning
i don't even want to look at another
human being until about 11 a.m and even
then i still don't want to look at
another human being
these kids they wake up every morning
every morning they wake up and they're
either singing like it's a you know a
karaoke night at the bar or they're
beating the hell out of each other
sometimes have anger sometimes out of
joy
sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference between the two
um they slept past 6 15 i think one time
in their lives but i i ruined it because
i i realized that it was like it's
already dawn and we haven't heard the
kids yet they haven't woken up the whole
house yet and so i thought they must be
dead or something and i ran in there
and then i woke them up and i ruined it
um
anyway that's not really what i what
what what did i want to complain about i
want to complain about daily savings
times right the thing that gets me about
this
is the only reason
we go through this
is that a german guy 100 years ago
wanted more time to look at bugs
i mean that's the reason daylight
savings time exists that's the origin
it's not for the farmers okay you still
hear people who say well we have
daylight savings
for the farmers
what how would that help how do you
think daylight savings time helps the
farmers
daylight savings doesn't actually adjust
the orbit
or the rotation of the earth it doesn't
affect the sun
okay so there's going to be the same
amount of sun as there was before the
crops don't care what time it is
no but this um this guy this german
freak this bud bug watcher he he knew
what time it was and it did affect him
and um he just thought it'd be easier
for him and his schedule and everything
and when he wants to eat dinner and all
that stuff if if we could if we could
move the clock ahead an hour and so he
suggested it to the world and the world
was like yeah okay
and we've been stuck with it ever since
because of that
in many ways this guy was the first
trans you know he was like a pioneer
he said we should all self-identify as
time travelers and move ahead an hour
and we did and we still do
for no reason now no one can explain why
i mean that guy's dead and gone he's
looked at all the bugs he wanted to look
at
it was very nice of us as a world to
accommodate him in that way but we're
still doing it and no one knows why
did he even accomplish i mean did he
like use that extra time to discover a
new species of centipede or something i
i don't know i think he just wasted it
all right uh let's start with this kyle
rittenhouse the kyle rittenhouse trial
is uh is continuing
and the theme here every day we've got
another video we've got we'll play one
today as well
of a prosecution witness
totally destroying and undermining the
prosecution's case and so we have
another
such case today um
this is
gage
gross crates i think is how you
pronounce his name he was uh one of the
guys who was shot he was there there are
three people shot by um
by kyle rittenhouse all three of them
attacking him and so he shot three
people in self-defense and this guy was
fortunate enough to survive it
which is why the media if you look at
the media headlines
they're referring to this guy who just
we're going to see in a second they're
referring to him as the lone survivor
of the
kyle rittenhouse shooting
that's not a that's not a misleading or
biased way of putting it is it
but he's a left-wing militant
and by all accounts and all appearances
in all around scumbag
um
and here he is admitting that
it takes him a little while to get there
but eventually he admits that he pointed
his gun at kyle rittenhouse he had a
loaded gun and he pointed at kyle ridden
house and that's when kyle pulled the
trigger let's listen
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
oh okay
[Music]
so he had a loaded gun
and there's that that exchange actually
goes on for a couple of minutes and
and uh he she tries to kind of purge
himself and at first he says when he's
asked the same question
well kyle redhouse didn't fire until he
pointed a gun he said he says oh that's
not true then they keep going through it
and finally he says okay yeah you're
right
and he has no choice but to admit it
because once again for the millionth
time this is all on video
so we know exactly what happened
and this man pointed a loaded gun at
kyle ridden house
um clear-cut
self-defense
this again is not simply a matter of uh
kyle rittenhouse is innocent he should
be acquitted
all of that is true
but the real point is that he never
should have been charged with anything
to begin with there was never any
evidence
in order to charge someone i'm not a
lawyer but i know this in order to
charge somebody with a crime there has
to be some kind of evidence
that they committed it and then you
bring and then the prosecution brings
that evidence the state brings that
evidence to a
jury of your peers and tries to prove
its case
but there's no evidence here at all
none
[Music]
all of the evidence that's available and
there's a substantial amount of evidence
available but all of it
is exculpatory all of it exonerates
uh the defendant
who never should have been a defendant
but what is what's he really on trial
for um as we know written house is on
trial for being
a non-leftist white male
that's why he's on trial that's that's
that is the rea he did commit a crime
kyle rittenhouse committed a crime
and the crime he committed he committed
it at birth
when he was born to white parents as a
man
as a boy
that's that's the real crime here
which is we hear about the left talks
about dog whistles all the time
constantly accusing everyone of dog
whistling i don't think they really know
what they mean when they use the term
anymore of course no words have have any
objective meaning when it comes as far
as these people are concerned
but talk about dog whistles
when you had
high-ranking democrats to include the
now president of the united states
calling kyle rittenhouse you know
immediately after this happened after
the shooting happened
uh joe biden alexandria casa cortez all
the squad i mean everything the media
the left
they all labeled him a white supremacist
there was never any evidence of that
whatsoever none
no indication of that
um he didn't and he didn't even none of
the people that he shot in self-defense
were black
even if he had it wouldn't make him a
white supremacist but this was a this
was white on white violence the whole
time
no reason to call him white supremacist
but that's a that's a dog whistle
what they really just mean to say is
that he's white
so when they say oh he needs to be
arrested and charged and he needs to rot
in a cage because he's a violent white
supremacist that's a dog whistle and
what it really means is he needs to rot
in a cage because he's a white male take
the supremacist part of out of it
any time you hear the left say white
supremacists just remove supremacist in
your mind
and then continue on with what they're
saying and that's what they really mean
all right what else we got here
you know speaking of white supremacy
speaking of non-existent white supremacy
did you know that there are the highways
there's also racism there's white
supremacy literally built into the
roadways
and pete butterjudge who is back from
paternity leave finally after about
three months has decided to um
just you woke up one day and decided you
know maybe i'll go to work
and um looking at everything that's
happening in the you know a country a
country in crisis on so many levels
what he's worried about
is the racism
built into the roadways let's listen to
this
can you give us
the construct of how you will
deconstruct the racism that was built
into the roadways that you talked to the
griot earlier when you broke that
information with us can you talk to us
about
how that could be deconstructed for sure
yeah so the principle of justice 40 is
that at least 40
of the clean investments in this bill
will go to benefit the communities that
are over burned and overburdened and
underserved so part one of that is
defining those those investments that
are eligible and that's a lot of it and
we're working to map out kind of program
by program mode by mode uh what would
qualify for example if we're uh buying
clean buses right how do we make sure in
terms of where those buses go but also
looking at the business opportunity the
jobs that are going to be created the
businesses that that will have a chance
to compete uh for for the business
opportunities it creates that too i
think is a very important element of
equity here that's in the spirit of
justice 40. and again we have a lot of
guidance and oversight from the white
house since that's an
administration-wide initiative
we know that we've got to build our own
internal uh kind of ways of of uh
aligning and defining that inside the
administration as to where we target
those those dollars you know i'm still
surprised that some people were
surprised when i pointed to the fact
that uh if
a highway was built for the purpose of
dividing a white in the black
neighborhood
or if an underpass was constructed such
that a bus carrying mostly black and
puerto rican kids uh to a beach or it
would have been uh in new york was was
designed uh too low for it to pass by
but that obviously reflects racism that
went into those design choices
yes how are we going to deak what did
you say deconstruct the construct
how will we deconstruct the construct
that's a dog whistle also that's a dog
whistle for
i'm a pretentious boar with nothing to
say deconstruct the construct
this is what we're worried about though
is uh race is that the highways
themselves
are racist and so now we need a very
literal sort of reparations tearing down
bridges
rebuilding highways
to uh heal the racial wounds of the past
also i also think you could argue that
the fact that um
highways are paved
in um you know you have black pavement
on the highways i think that's also
probably racist
what message does that send
every single day you as a as a white
person you are driving
on a black
pavement
sending a message i suppose that black
people are uh beneath you so i think we
should probably repave all the roads
paint them
uh paint them i'll paint them white
might be a little bit the glare might be
a little bit tough but we should try
that
we could paint them rainbow colors
they're actually they actually are doing
that in some in some cities especially
in canada
but then again that that sends the wrong
message then you're trampling on on gay
pride you don't want to do that so i
think we i think we pave all the roads
white
put white put put the color white
beneath the tread of our tires where it
belongs
um what else we got here this is a
terrible
terrible story a terrible update to a
terrible story a story that just gets
worse and worse
in the days the days following this
tragedy it says this is from the daily
beast now it says a nine-year-old
who was crushed and trampled at travis
scott's astro world festival on friday
is fighting for his life in the hospital
um ezra blount who uh attended the
festival with his father suffered major
organ damage and was in medically
induced coma
as of monday according to abc 13 a woman
identifying herself as blo
blunt's auntie wrote on instagram the
child had damage and trauma to his
livers kidneys brain heart and lungs
[Music]
it says that
the child's father placed him on his
shoulders to keep him above the chaos
the father was crushed and passed out
and then the child fell he got trampled
and now he's
hanging on
for for dear life
uh so these this is why i said yesterday
this we have to keep in mind
first of all the the eight people that
killed that's that that's the body count
that's the the death toll right now it
could it could tragically climb
and these are mostly kids
and i said that thinking these are
probably you know 13 14 15 16 year olds
uh i had i didn't imagine a nine year
old and it does raise the question you
know of
what what in god's name was a
nine-year-old
doing at
at this kind of music festival
with travis scott i mean this isn't um
like the wiggles or raffi in concert or
something this isn't uh veggie tales
uh
this is travis scott's music i'm not
really a travis scott fan i don't
pretend to be an expert in his music
but having just listened very briefly to
get a taste of it it's exactly what i
expected
degenerate disgusting filth
all of the music is about
mostly just about doing drugs violence i
mean all that kind of stuff that's all
the music and there's there's a young
child there
you know you got to put you you
obviously have to put responsibility on
the parents i mean bringing your kid
to an event like this is
it's inexcusable but also this goes to
the to the organizers the people running
the event how is there not an age limit
how do you let a nine-year-old
if there's a parent reckless enough to
try to bring a nine-year-old into an
event like that how are they not turned
away at the door
so we're so concerned about the health
and safety of nine-year-olds
that uh when they go to school they
gotta wear masks for covet 19 but we're
going to let them into a wrap to a to a
rap festival
with 50 000 people in the middle of a
you know giant 50 000 person mosh pit
listening to music promoting drugs and
violence and sex and everything else
so
one thing in our society and this is one
of the this is one of the many tragic
consequences of it is that
our culture just has no respect for or
understanding of
um
childhood
and the innocence of childhood
and what sort of content is appropriate
for kids
you're right there many parents like
this and fortunately it doesn't it most
of the time it doesn't have the
immediate
violent tragic uh consequences that we
find in this case but you run into a
great many parents who just have they
have kids but they have no clue
no concept
of what children are psychologically or
physically prepared to handle
i mean there
there are plenty of parents out there at
nine years old 10 years old
you know as i've railed against many
times they give their kid a phone with
full internet access and say yeah go go
uh go
just spend two hours on youtube i'm sure
there's nothing there that's not
appropriate for you
meanwhile i don't know 95 of it is not
appropriate for kids that age
many parents have no understanding of
this at all um of what is appropriate
for kids what what it means to be a
child
um how you know
how to protect a child's innocence or
why they should protect it to begin with
and this is a problem that goes back
through the generations and many times
because their parents weren't focused on
that kind of thing i mean many of these
kids many of these parents now when they
were kids they came home from public
school to empty homes because both
parents were working or was a single
parent home or whatever
and they had no kind of parental
guidance at all and and so they just
in order to know how to be a parent
you know as as a child that's that's
when you learn a lot of lessons about
what it means to be a parent that you
will take with you even if you don't
realize it you're going to take it with
you into adulthood
this is not any great insight right
you learn
parenting from your own parents and you
take cues from them
a lot of parents today with kids
basically were not parented
and so they have no idea
um
there need to be there need to be
criminal charges uh in this case all
over the place i think travis scott
should be among the ones who faces
who face criminal charges
all right
what else we got here i wanted to
mention this this is from
yaf.org it says a catholic university in
missouri is investigating a conservative
student group for refusing to bow to the
anti-science left according to a tip
received through yaf's campus bias
tipline the saint louis university
college republicans received a letter
from the school's office of student
responsibility community standards
informing them of an investigation into
a video posted on the organization's
instagram page
um
it says that uh
basically saying the video is harmful
and it's a violation of the handbook the
college republicans used a famous line
from delhi wire host matt walsh asking
the liberals liberal students to define
what a woman is the video which racked
up nearly a thousand views poked fun at
the leftist group slu [ __ ] that's the
group that's what they call themselves
slu [ __ ]
who argue that not all women have a
uterus and not all people with uteruses
are women
so
um
and this by the way yeah i'm pretty sure
let me see here yeah okay so this is
supposedly a catholic university
um
and i bring this up because so the
conservatives on campus
asking this question that i that i have
asked so many times what is a woman
they're being investigated by the campus
for that the group slu [ __ ] uh the
[ __ ] are not happy about it the [ __ ]
are very upset again self-professed lutz
that's that's what they call themselves
um
i was really and i am i'm gonna be
speaking at slu on december first and
that's where this that's where a lot of
this comes from
i was originally planning a different
topic
but given how upset
the [ __ ] are and the campuses at the
what is a woman question now i know that
when i speak on december 1st that is
going to be the entire topic of my of my
talk so
um the conservatives on campus did a
one-minute video with what is a woman
uh camp the university didn't like that
so now i'm going to give you a 45-minute
speech on it
on just that topic and so if you're
anywhere in town or if you go to slu
make sure you're there on december 1st
all right what else do we have howard
stern is very upset
at um
aaron
rodgers because he didn't get vaccinated
as we continue with this uh
controversy over the fact that you know
an nfl player decided
you know made decisions for his own body
decided you want to get vaccinated
howard stern very upset about it let's
listen to uh stern for a minute
i was so
worked up
over the weekend
about this in uh aaron rodgers of the
nfl i don't even know where to begin
with that story i mean this [ __ ] guy
i don't watch football sorry i'm not a
big fan
i know the guy's a real good football
player that's why they put up with this
[ __ ]
if i ran the nfl he's going to be a hall
of famer so yeah you know that he's
important to the franchise
if i was the you know if there was
decency in this world
you know i would throw this guy out of
the football league so fast what he did
to his fellow teammates
and you know bravo terry bradshaw for
what you said and everyone else who's
got half a brain in this country but
this
guy they should throw him out of the
league so fast
with the guy who crashed this car at 153
miles an hour and some
howard stern is worried about decency if
we had any decent howard stern is
concerned about decency
but this is the new and proved howard
stern like i was i was never a big
howard stern fan
but obviously at least back in the day
in the 90s
you know he was on his his whole career
was defined by
a crusade against political correctness
and you just have to imagine that the
howard stern of 1993 let's say or how
about the howard stern of 1991 looking
30 years into the future at the howard
stern of 2021 how would that how would
the 91 stern feel about the 21 the 2021
stern
i mean he would hate that guy
and for good reason
this is why you know howard stern is
what he's like 85 years old now
at a certain point you just got to pack
it in
go go to your mansion
with all of your many millions and enjoy
the rest of your life
whatever whatever legacy he had has been
totally destroyed
this is what he's become now
now he's uh now howard stern is a
defender of the status quo
howard stern is crying about the
indecency of football players
because he didn't get a vaccine what he
did to his teammates what did he do his
teammates exactly what are you talking
about what what
explain that a little bit more
well he doesn't explain it i mean i cut
him off but all he does he just
continues this is his whole argument ah
this effing guy didn't get the vaccine i
mean come on
this effing guy
that's his whole argument
very eloquent
um
of course he's you know now howard stern
is a new improved decent howard stern
but he also can't say more than four
words without dropping an f-bomb so
that's you know that's his version of
decency i don't know
but i'd like to hear i'd like to hear
some kind of argument what exactly did
aaron rodgers do to his teammates i mean
how did he harm anybody
these are all people who for them covet
poses almost no risk at all already
because they're young
men
very physically fit
and they're vaccinated so what harm did
he do
that can't be explained
all right let's move to this
really we've just been leading up to
this i think it's the most important
story
snopes has a fact check on the claim
that joe biden farted while meeting with
the duchess of cornwall
and the verdict right now from snopes
they did look into this and they say the
verdict is unproven so this is what they
say an anonymous source told the daily
mail the u.s president biden farted
during his meeting with the duchess of
cornwall despite headlines claiming that
camilla parker bowles can't stop talking
about it duchess has offered no public
comments on the matter it should also be
noted that this rumor started amid a
series of unfounded claims regarding
presidential farts
no other evidence has emerged about
these alleged emissions no other sources
have acknowledged this possible piece of
presidential flatulence and while a
number of news outlets have repeated the
claim that the duchess of cornwall
hasn't stopped talking about it she has
not made any public comments about biden
breaking wind so snope says we can't
confirm or debunk whether biden truly
farted while meeting with the duchess of
cornwall we can say that the evidence
for this uh fart is scarce that it's
based entirely on a single quote from an
anonymous source and that it's made its
way around the internet on the heels of
several other false fart rumors now uh
they have declared these other rumors
they've declared them rumors and they've
said that they're false but we don't
know that either
so there's a lot we don't know and we've
got to be honest about the situation i
think i think when when you're staring
at a situation and uh and there's
there's there's really no evidence one
way or another you've got to be honest
about it did joe biden release exhaust
from the tailpipe right in front of a
member of the royal family
did he do this only a week after dumping
a load in his pants in front of the pope
um
these are questions we have no answer to
all we can do is we can look at patterns
all right
and there does seem to be
an undeniable pattern
wherein joe biden is being accused of of
of
gastrological activity shall we say
often in front of notable international
figures
his colon seems to be especially
aggressive
in europe in particular
is there a connection there is this even
part of some kind of national defense
strategy i don't know is joe biden
being sent over to these other world
powers to deploy something of kind of a
skunk strategy sort of emitting an odor
as as a way to warn off
predators on the national or the
international stage
i don't know
i can't say nobody can say
i just wish that our media would start
asking these kinds of questions
um
if i were in the media i would
but you know they they
they would ask joe biden about uh
about what what flavor ice cream he
likes
but they won't ask about the flatulence
potentially caused by that ice cream all
i could say for sure this is one thing
we know for sure let's just hope that
joe biden and eric swalwell are never in
the same room together
all kinds of epa regulations will be
violated in a situation like that so i
think we could say that at least all
right now let's move on to the comment
section
um frank says growing up in the 90s to
mosh pits with the likes of slayer
pantera anthrax etc there was an
unspoken respect where you don't touch
anyone not in the pit as they are
clearly not willing participants seeing
this happen at a hip-hop concert
is not the least bit surprising yes the
uh the etiquette of the mosh pit yeah
that was a thing but but but with this
concert it sounds like as i said the
whole crowd is one big mosh pit
um and uh
and these things just have a
domino effect once the panic
sets in in the crowd and everybody's
trapped in there you see how
uh tragedy soon follows
taimi shu says matt in reference to
ashley biden's diary is it normal for an
adult to shower with a child if so at
what age does that have to stop
um yeah there are some more allegations
quite a bit more serious
than the fart allegations well it
shouldn't stop at all because it
shouldn't start
no it is not normal at all even a little
not at all no
um
elijah says there's only one video of
travis stopping the show once for like
three seconds then he went right back to
performing uh yeah i did see that so
i've seen
initially there were claims that travis
scott stopped the performance multiple
times to try to calm the crowd down
and uh i've since seen one video where
he stops it for as you say a couple of
seconds and then goes right back into it
there are also videos of him
on the stage while people are collapsing
in cardiac arrest and he seems to be
looking right at them
while still singing in his garbage
auto-tune voice
um
jonathan swank says matt tomorrow you
should cancel equity
yeah um
yeah you know the right this this is
this is a line that and sure i'll cancel
equity uh equity inequality they're kind
of
but this is a line that the right tries
to draw a lot well they'll say well we
don't want equity but we do want
equality
that's that's another false choice
because really as i explained yesterday
they're both bad
william says matt you're wrong that
equality is a woman's virtue men are
more competitive indeed but the attitude
of best man wins is predicated on the
idea
that the competition is fair in the
first place
men champion equality of opportunity
equality of outcome or equity is what
women are more likely to champion to
want everyone to end up at the same
place regardless of skill ability or
attitude for no one to lose and feel bad
about not being as good as somebody else
that is a womanly trait but it is not
equality it is equity men want equality
specifically so that the best man wins
yeah i know again here's here's another
kind of false choice that you find on
the right trying to thread this needle
and saying well we don't want equality
of outcome we want a quality of
opportunity
but even that i i
equality of opportunity is also a
fiction i don't know exactly what you
mean by that you're depending on where
you live
um
[Music]
what your basic skills are
uh how you were raised i mean all kinds
of things are going to determine
not only outcome but they're also going
to determine what sort of opportunities
are presented to you
okay this is not this is not a pitch for
systemic racism because it's not about
racism
it's just that
everybody is unequal and they're an
unequal situation doesn't mean that
one's superior to another
it's just that we all are in vastly
different situations
and so to even say that
we have equality of opportunity i think
that is also a problem to use the left's
term here it is problematic to talk
about equality of opportunity
because what are you going to do to make
sure that every single person in the
country has the exact same opportunities
as every other person that is just not a
reality it's not
i think we need to we need to re-center
ourselves in reality
now
um does that mean that uh we should be
okay with
um people being foreclosed opportunities
being foreclosed from from for people no
so i think what we should be talking
about is maybe uh you know freedom of
opportunity
what we want
we want everyone to have the freedom to
pursue whatever opportunities
are um
available to them or you know we want
everyone to have that kind of freedom
and that ability
but i don't think the opportunities are
actually going to be equal i think
that's a that's another fiction that's a
story that we tell ourselves
and uh i just don't think it's true
i hate to say it there is so like i said
yesterday the daily cancellation
equality is a fiction
well now your favorite time of the show
the daily wire promos it's been a year
since joe biden was elected president
and it's time to unpack everything the
democrats have screwed up since then and
the pushback that's now happening tune
in tomorrow to catch an all-new episode
of backstage where we discuss the
turning of the tide we're keeping it
broad i like that what's this what
subject we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about the dems screwing
things up
for a change you know we're going to
talk about that join me ben shapiro
jeremy bohr michael knowles and andrew
clavin tomorrow at seven o'clock eastern
6 pm central on daily
and on our youtube channel dailywire but
wait there's more it's been nearly a
week since the daily wire filed a
lawsuit against the federal government
our senile leader ordered the large
employers require their employees to be
vaccinated as you know we're not going
to stand for that we are fighting back
against it and uh we need your help and
the number one thing you can do to help
us is become a member if you're not a
member yet please consider joining today
if you go to dailywire.com subscribe and
enter code do not comply at checkout
you'll receive 25 off your membership
and you'll be fighting this
unconstitutional mandate with us we
appreciate your help we won't comply and
neither should you thedaleywire.com
uh again that's dailywire.com subscribe
code do not comply for 25 off and we
have one more
special treat now for some good news
well
those were supposed to be good news also
so now for a third piece of good news
we're launching daily wire now which
means you'll be able to stream all of
your favorite daily wire shows on vizio
smartcast tune in to watch candice
discuss current events with guests
ranging from donald trump to dana white
or you can catch one of your favorite
hosts uh there's always something
interesting to stream watch daily wire
now exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast and wait there's more no there
is that's it let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel the republican party
once again it's canceled for this news
as reported by the uh by cns news it
says the republican national committee
announced its partnership with the log
cabin republicans at donald trump's
mar-a-lago resort this weekend creating
its first pride coalition which will
invest and mobilize lgbtq plus
communities ahead of the 2022 midterm
elections according to fox news the
spirit of lincoln gala held at the
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida was
hosted by the log cabin republicans an
organization representing lgbtq
conservatives and their allies on
saturday night
as president trump referred to
mar-a-lago as his winter white house he
and his wife melania trump were the
guests of honor at saturday's event
now
i criticized the rnc pride coalition on
twitter and it upset a number of people
many of them republicans including
richard grinnell who's the um the acting
or was the the acting director of
national intelligence under trump and
the first openly gay person to serve at
a cabinet level position
uh he was at the event at mar-a-lago as
well and he received an award as well i
think
he took issue with my criticism along
with a number of other prominent
republicans both gay and straight
grinnell accused me of among other
things being uh he said i was from the
stone age for having a problem with the
rnc pride coalition
i take great exception to that i am not
from the stone age it will be more
accurate to say that i'm from the middle
ages
though frankly i would prefer the stone
age over the current age i would take
that in a heartbeat
now i have been repeatedly accused not
just because of this issue but in
general of trying to exclude gay people
from the conservative movement
that's not the case
what i want to exclude
what i say we must exclude if we want
conservatism to mean anything at all
is gay pride
i do not think that there should be an
lgbt pride coalition in the republican
party and i'll explain why and let me
know at the beginning that if we were
back in the ancient times of not the
stone ages or even the middle ages but
say five years ago it would have been
totally uncontroversial for me to
suggest that gay pride doesn't belong in
the conservative movement
but as we know the republican party is
on the same train as the democrat party
just a few cars behind and as the whole
the whole locomotive
speeds inexorably to the left the
republican party is never far behind
that's how a statement that would have
been so self-evident as to be boring
five years ago can suddenly be not only
provocative
but downright offensive today
so here's the problem with gay pride and
why it doesn't belong in the
conservative movement
it's hard to know even where to begin i
mean you often have that problem when
trying to explain things that should be
obvious
so i'll stick with two points here uh
starting with the most fundamental
gay pride is an ideology it's a
philosophy
and as such like any ideology or
philosophy it has a history
and we can trace that history
and when you trace the history of gay
pride which isn't hard to do because
history goes back only a few decades
you find that it was from the beginning
has always been and is now an
anti-family anti-virtue
anti-christian left-wing phenomenon
there's a reason why harvey milk the
child raping peters is a gay pride hero
he may not be a hero of all gay people
individually but gay pride again is an
ideology
and within that ideology men like harvey
milk are honored and celebrated gay
pride parades are fully in accordance
with the gay pride
philosophy and that is why they are
hedonistic self-indulgent
self-worshiping hyper-sexualized
spectacles of decadence and debauchery
it's not a coincidence or a matter of
happenstance that gay pride parades and
festivals take on this character that's
what gay pride the ideology is all about
and has always been about
why is that well because gay pride
revolves around
really it invented we should say
sexual identity politics
according to gay pride ideology
according to sexual identity politics
the most important thing about a person
the number one defining trait is their
sexual proclivity
a person is encouraged to find their
identity to locate themselves within
this proclivity
that is not conservative
if that is conservative then
conservatism is totally
indistinguishable from leftism
at best it becomes a different side of
the same coin though i think it really
would be the same side of the same coin
or a coin where the two sides are so
similar that it would be really hard to
try and play heads or tails with them
again i emphasize
everything i've said here
would have been considered insane up
until about five years ago insane only
because it's so obvious that it
shouldn't need to be said
a segment on a conservative talk show
explaining why gay pride isn't
conservative would have been like a
segment on the weather channel
explaining why
the rain makes you wet
this just shows you how thoroughly how
cataclysmic glue the the ground has
shifted beneath our feet
and many people on the right have been
moved all the way to the left without
even noticing that they moved at all
this is what happens when you allow
yourself to passively float on the tide
of culture you look up one day and you
notice that you've drifted far from
where you started though you weren't
trying to go anywhere at all
right-wing gay pride is as a concept
very similar to right-wing feminism
and there are indeed conservatives who
for years have been trying to develop a
conservative feminism
oftentimes they say that they want to
reclaim the spirit of feminism in its
original form
in its pure and eudenic state
back in the mythic first wave period
when feminist pioneers were fighting for
the good you know fighting the good
fight and saying a lot of really
conservative things like uh quote the
bible and the church have been the
greatest stumbling blocks in the way of
women's emancipation
that was elizabeth stanton god mother of
feminism
said that over a hundred years ago in
the first wave
identifying the bible and church as the
enemies
in the first wave of feminism
in fact all of feminism's godmothers
said stuff like that about religion the
family men marriage
feminism as it turns out
was
at the time
still is
anti-family anti-christian anti-virtue
anti-man from its very inception
there is no pure form of it to return to
it is rotten to its core
like gay pride
feminism is one of the worst things to
ever happen to the human race it is one
of the greatest evils in history
it's killed 60 million babies and that's
just the start
and yet some conservatives still think
it's possible to be a conservative
feminist
not realizing
that it's it's it's you know it's not a
it's not a corruption of feminism in its
original form it is its culmination
today's feminism
is the culmination
of
the original feminism
a culmination not a corruption
the same can be said when you see drag
queens story hours or men in bondage
gear marching down the street in front
of children
that's not a corruption of gay pride it
is gay pride
that's what the ideology of lgbt pride
stands for
and speaking of lgbt what about what
about the t in that um
in that initialism
i asked grinnell this and he didn't
answer but it's a good question
are we including the t in this
conservative pride
are we proud of transgenderism now too
are we embracing gender theory
perhaps looking for a pure conservative
form of gender theory
what's next conservative critical race
theory
conservative marxism
conservative communism where does it end
maybe we can come up with our own
conservative satanism
dems are the real satan phobes
that's where it ends really it ends in
confusion impotence the death of
anything resembling conservatism
unless we come to our senses and start
drawing clear lines
and until we do that i must say
the republican party is canceled and so
is gay pride gay pride is cancelled too
of course and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
tells american companies to follow his
vaccine mandate even though it's
unconstitutional the price of gas rises
at the pump but joe biden is shutting
down another pipeline and iconoclastic
intellectuals open a new university
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen